hey guys so I found out that j.lo and  Shakira they were supposed to sing the  star-spangled banner at the Super Bowl  but then Demi Lovato was like and I want  to sing it so I figured I could sing  that the national anthem for you as JLo  and Chiquita back and forth and hope you  like  [Music]  oh say can you see by the dawn's early  light what so proudly we hailed at the  twilight's last gleaming whose broad  stripes and bright stars through the  perilous fight for the ramparts we  watch'd were so gallantly streaming and  the Rockets red glare Abu Dis bursting  in the end game proved about night that  our flag was from the Bronx oh say does  that star-spangled booty get away or the  women are the most free Miescher the  most  I play ball you